hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
I'm Taylor chambers and this is Tamra
just saw try to make out but I didn't we
just saw the jungle hell yeah we saw Hey
Arnold going up yeah it was our TV it
was one of those those Aaron in the in
the 90s Rachael tea today when we moved
here we watched the entire series of
heralds because it was on Netflix and we
didn't know anyone and we were only 20s
we couldn't like go out at night so we
stayed in and we watched Harold with the
fire that burns like a thousand suns oh
I have a little heart pendant yeah do
you ever shrine in your closet for Ike
mhm
so after 15 years they have decided to
take the cliffhanger that they left us
with at the series finale and make the
jungle movie thank God thank God we're
II watched the very last episode which
is writing the journal right before we
watched the jump on TV just to like kind
of brush off because it takes place well
directly after yeah it seems so after
some research we found that they didn't
want that to be the end of the series
and they also didn't want the jungle
movie obviously to come out this late
they were going to do the jungle movie
as a theatrical release and then the
movie that was a theatrical release the
Hey Arnold movie was just gonna be for
the channel for Nickelodeon and for some
reason they got switched the movie that
was not supposed to be a theatrical
release did poorly because it's bad and
then this was never made for some reason
you do it 15 I'm madly in caps
I tend some too much and that's why you
gotta keep them loose and wait and like
moist
it aired on Nickelodeon we ended up
watching it on Amazon it's like it's
been out for like a weekend half two
weeks now and it was $4.99 on Amazon so
well worth the money if you haven't seen
it though if you haven't seen it
there are definitely going to be
spoilers in this reaction video so tread
lightly it was very sweet and the exact
ending I needed for this show and I felt
like after all of this time and after
loving this goddamn wholesome ass show
for so long it was like the ending that
I needed first first impression
especially since we had just watched the
very last episode right before this the
animation is weird it is so different
it's more modern but like just the stark
contrast to what it was is more
hand-drawn and like not more it was
hand-drawn yeah and now it's just it's
just weird the grandpa when he first
walks any like whoo there it is yeah and
it's a little bit of a bummer because in
the last episode number there's like
this sunset I was like oh my god it's
beautiful which is like something you
don't see very often now and and this
one it there was a lot of like 3d action
going on it looked it look cleaner but
like it lost some of the originality so
that's kind of the thing that's yeah
they threw in the weird 3d bit and it's
like it just looked like clay and it's
like I don't like this yeah it sometimes
works sometimes like very specific anime
sometimes sometimes but not if it's a
mess it's a big mess yeah and this one
it didn't look too great and I also
again I think it really hit home for us
because we had just finished watching
the last episode of the actual series
the voices were a pretty good match and
I don't know if any of them were from
the original cast I don't imagine 15
years later older sister Olga yeah she's
done exactly the same also Helga how
good was a great all of the same like
all the Buccos and all of the football
heads and they all sounded perfect so
that was really nice I'm glad they
didn't like cut quarters with the voice
acting because way more than the
animation that would have really
bothered me I think
the characters were still very much
themselves they gave each of the side
characters like they at least had up
couple lines each oh when it's revealed
through his passport and his last name
is short man that's so cool
Gramps has been saying it the whole time
we both like oh hey Arnold's class
enters this thing to go to San Lorenzo
for a field trip this humanitarian
project and they have to submit a video
and they submit a video about hey Arnold
and in it you get to see a bunch of
skits from what the series had shown coz
Harold's always been such a like cool
chill ass dude who's just doing good all
the time series highlights so he had the
highlight of all the like him saving the
Turtles and like him getting mr. uh off
his roommate guy his daughter back like
all the nice things that he did in
disaster artists when you see them
recreate the scenes and it's like I know
that scene and it's fun to see it brand
new same kind of thing here because they
did it in the new animation oh yeah yeah
so it was kind of fun to see it again
but like redone that's that's exciting
yeah so that was definitely my favorite
part of it the new animation is to see
like the old stuff with the new that's
fun oh god is there like you said how
does sister her older sister and her
voice is so funny
it's so funny she always sounds like
she's about to cry but she's so happy -
one of the best parts until you get to
the end is when Helga finally plucks up
the courage to go upstairs with Arnold
and she proclaims her like like for him
almost love and then they get attacked
by that's why she can't quiet go before
she says that sure I love it I thought
was a dream because like the whole
series she had been trying to build that
turn around
that yeah and she just goes for it and
you're like good for you girls so after
the first like half of the film it's
basically just Helga Arnold and Gerald's
and they're going around there trying to
find the green eyed people and they're
trying to find his parents and so they
find the green eyed people you're pretty
good job they do a pretty damn damn good
job guys even when this evil guy is
coming after him yeah so the Pirate King
coming after him all right so anyway
they play it up and they play down and
play it up and they play down so many
times that like the parents are alive
they're dead they're alive they're death
they find the cure for the sleeping
sickness and then they take away the
cure for the sleeping sickness and then
the sleeping sickness fear is Helga's
Lockett and then then the parents are
alive I I was I was I was crying young
he wakes up the next morning in his bed
and he thinks it's a dream yeah that's
it being real and then his parents
follow him to school because we we
already miss you
is so sweet kisses Helga yeah he's like
none of this would have happened without
you and I know that you mean to me
because you love me and then he kisses
her and it's really sweet 15 years later
15 years a finger I've ever waited for
in my life in the end it was wrapped up
so well it was I I just said this it's
it's just a bull cartoon and it's like
the animation is very simple the stories
are really simple
the characters are simple the writing is
simple the jokes are simple but it's so
wholesome and so like you feel lighter
after you watch the episode especially
like that we watched one that was 40
minutes but it's usually there for 20
minute long episodes and they're really
just like you learn the lesson people
grow it's like it's genuine it's not
like a full house lesson it's like a
it's like a lesson lesson and like you
feel good after and it's sweet as hell
and it's wholesome as book
it's great this is such a back in my day
rant but like curtains nowadays are just
so they got the spongebob trend of like
Oh nonsensical funny will just make
everything in the show nonsensical and
complete nonsense and the kids will go
crazy and they do that but that it's
just that's all it is though now and so
it's like there's no substance it's just
like well his parents he kissed Olga
five dollars on amazon if you haven't
seen it it's definitely worth the hour
and twenty minutes that we spent
watching it it's totally totally what
you want if you were a fan of the show
they did a really good job just like
being like wow we really go over
everyone who loved this show fifteen
years ago let's give them the ending
they always deserved and they did it
really well and it was it was nice
almost as good as the emoji movie so
close the next week we're gonna see Star
Wars yeah Star Wars the last Jedi is
next week and um thank oh dang I'm gonna
go in costume kind of the Praetorian I
have to rate costumes if you want to
wear one
[Laughter]
[Music]